okay we have Zach Jost from Amazon he's
a research scientist working in Seattle
so we spent the first half an hour or so
talking about YouTube how we all run our
channels and what our philosophy is on
YouTube we went on to talk about the
bring your own latent paper so it's
really important that you go and watch
an X video on that just to get a feel
for what we're talking about but that
bring your own latent paper is a new
approach to unsupervised contrastive
learning but you no longer need to do
negative sampling you completely
dispatched the need the negative
sampling and after that we went on to
talk about knowledge graphs and
graphical models in machine learning we
talked about some applications of this
so fraud detection and then afterwards
we finished off by talking about
automated machine learning and people
who know me know that I'm quite cynical
about automated machine learning so we
had a great conversation about that
anyway remember to Like comment and
subscribe and we'll see you back next
week
[Laughter]
you look like you're coming from a
propaganda video or something amazing
well welcome back to the machine
learning Street talk YouTube channel
with me Tim scarf my two compadres
Yannick Kilcher and Connor shorten today
we have an incredibly exciting guest
from Amazon and Zak Jost is a research
scientist he works over in Seattle and
he has several channels that he
publishes really interesting content to
his followers so he's got a YouTube
channel called welcome AI overlords he's
got a discord server and he's also got a
blog his interests are deep learning
graphs in machine learning and knowledge
graphs and various approaches to
represent graphical information
automated machine learning generative
adversarial networks machine learning
security and fraud detection so Zak
welcome to the show well thanks for the
intro yeah happy to be here I'm a big
fan of all of you guys so it's really
cool to be a part of this so thanks
amazing so why don't you tell us a
little bit about your story I mean how
did you launch the YouTube channel how
did you get the job at Amazon and have
you been a machine learning aficionado
your entire
like it was just funny thing yeah first
of all I'd like to hear your guys's
stories too if there's time but mine is
this physics is my educational
background so I was working in some nano
material stuff and ended up getting a
job in the semiconductor industry is
starting out as a process engineer so
doing ion implantation there's a pretty
fascinating topic but I won't digress
into that now anywho later on I would
say the data science term started coming
into the kind of popular parlance and
you had like the DJ Patil and Hilary
Mason and those early famous kind of
data scientists and I got interested in
the field because as part of my job that
the thing I really excelled at and
enjoyed was the data analysis piece so
we would run these controlled
experiments trying to understand the
physical processes and and use
statistics to choose which changes to
make to the process to improve it and I
really enjoyed that and kind of dove
deeper into statistics and got it into
my head that I'd like to learn more
about machine learning so I started kind
of studying in my free time in the
evenings and stuff learning Python and
all the the stuff that comes with it
right like getting how to install all
this stuff on a Windows machine it just
it was pretty daunting in the beginning
but you know you kind of chip away at it
a little bit at a time and then long
story short I had ended up quitting that
job to focus solely on closing that
remaining knowledge gap once I got a
little closer and eventually landed at
Capital One as my first data scientist
position and moved to Texas so I was
there for about 18 months and learned a
lot from the people there about actually
doing data sciences as opposed to kind
of just getting my toe dipped into the
water with tutorials and all that stuff
so got some real practical experience of
building models in a production
environment and all the regulatory stuff
and requirements around operation of
these things so eventually I decided I
wanted to come out to Seattle I have a
cousin here and he was at Microsoft for
a long time and so started applying and
eventually got on
AWS and it's been just a amazing
experience that the people there have
there's just so much knowledge and so
many opportunities and people have
diverse backgrounds and have worked on
so many cool problems so it's just like
a very fast acceleration of the learning
rate for me so that's been really cool
and have been here about three years
we're currently I'm working on the
Amazon fraud detector service so I
started out in the internal fraud group
where we were trying to find a fraud in
internal to the AWS platform and built a
lot of machine learning stuff around
that and the DevOps piece of it and then
a group of us from that group kind of
split off to work on this external
service which is now in preview so been
doing that for a little while and how
did it you know how did the the YouTube
channel come come about oh yeah so I met
a guy to Kiel so shout outs is a keel he
posted a video on LinkedIn that I found
pretty inspiring it we didn't know each
other
prior to this and it was about him sort
of being rejected for like the 15th time
from Facebook or something like that and
how he was it was a very optimistic
video of just sort of keeping grinding
and I reached out to him basically
offering any help that I could because
he was in the Seattle area and he seemed
like you know someone of upstanding
character and talent so I was gonna see
if I could get him into Amazon and then
we just sort of started hanging out
occasionally and he said to me cuz he
had a lot of experience with social
media and that sort of thing he said hey
you should start a YouTube channel and I
kind of laughed it off but then it
planted the bug and then the more I
thought about it oh my god why not you
know and then I started thinking about
how that would happen and then just sort
of putting a couple videos out and then
just got hooked it it's been so much fun
and then now that it started to expand
into similar to you guys trying to find
like first authors of papers and getting
them on it's just been so exciting to
have an excuse to reach out to these
people and talk to them and and pick
their brains you know usually it would
it would seem strange to just randomly
email someone
to ask them whatever silly questions you
have but for some reason if you
broadcast it on the Internet it
justifies that's so true I would
articulate it in a similar way being
plugged into this Nexus it's a forcing
function and I've never felt more
passionate and more kind of switched on
by all of this stuff every single day
and my note of notification feeds I've
got you know Jannik just posted this
video over here and Connor posted it
over here and it's just created this
incredible energy that I don't think I
would have had if I wasn't creating
content so no I honestly think that
there's something magical not only about
consuming content but also creating it
yeah totally like the house of written a
little bit of blog articles and stuff
and the way that started was you know
you work really hard to dive in deep to
really learn something and for me if I
write it down it's like okay next time I
need to learn this thing these are my
notes to shortcut so I don't have to do
all that really tedious work again you
know and then you put it on the internet
and hopefully other people find some
value out of it as well
and but like you said it's also this
kind of feedback mechanism this forcing
function it's like okay well since I'm
going to put this on the Internet
I might may as well like really do my
homework on these other things or maybe
I'll reach out to this person and
something about publishing makes you
just behave differently and you know for
this talk I prepared in red papers that
I wouldn't normally have read and it's
just this really nice flywheel effect I
think that's a big part of it you know
on github for example as soon as you get
someone to publish their work on github
the quality will go up because it's
observable to everyone what's your take
on like your experience writing and
making videos because I also I started
off writing blog post polishing them on
medium and towards data science and then
I started making YouTube videos and now
I haven't had the motivation to write it
like I think the video making it there's
something to like talking through it
that I think you learn so much more than
taking the notes and writing it down
yeah I agree with that there's also just
so many hours in a day and the video
something about that video I don't know
if it's the novelty but it's just gotten
my attention and then therefore it falls
off on the other stuff but yeah I agree
being able to also construct a visual
content I think that goes along with
that narrative really kind of unlocks
something in my brain but I'm sitting
there thinking like well what's the best
visual that I can come up with it really
demonstrates the essence of this and I
don't know if it just activates a
different reasoning portion of my brain
or something to think about the problem
differently this kind of geometric
interpretation or something but yeah I
agree there's something really
satisfying about the visual part of
YouTube and enforcing yourself to put
that together
that's fascinating it turns on another
part of your brain in a way when you
write an article it's far more technical
in a way it's higher fidelity but when
you when you create a video you have the
capability to present it in a myriad of
different ways I use music on my videos
you can use graphics and another thing
is it's honing your presentation skills
because you're practicing I mean I
typically do several takes when I do my
videos and I'm practicing how to
articulate and distill something down
the distillation bits interesting as
well because that they say you only
understand something well when you've
distilled it and can explain it so to
layman's so that there's something about
the process of content creation which
really helps your own learning yeah
absolutely
yeah I just think it's so much harder to
record yourself presenting it than it is
to write down the notes like you know
you have to remember it really when
you're gonna be talking about it in a
different way yeah do you guys have when
you record yourselves do you have some
sort of thing you're looking at or
prompt or do you actually memorize it
how do you go about that well I know
from experience that people can tell if
you're reading from a script' I try I
try to do that because of course it's
it's so much easier if you read from a
script but what I do now is
I just think of high-level meta points
and I will just say them out loud
several times and through repetition it
really sticks in your mind because then
I'll be on a conference call at work or
something and I'll say oh yeah basically
they were doing this this and this and
and you can articulate it almost like a
generative function it sounds slightly
different every time but it rolls off
the tongue and I think if you can't
trust yourself to verbalize something
off the cuff I don't think you really
know it yeah I know when I started early
on the as soon as you click the button
to record like the first few times and
that big cameras just pointed right at
your dumb face you're just nerves kick
in and like your brain just doesn't work
and you're so harsh and judging yourself
it's like you know you don't nail it the
first take and it's like ah man what am
I doing here it didn't like my wife is
in the room the first time and that
shouldn't do that you just starting out
you should definitely be alone I think
but I think what I've learned through
doing it more is just to have a little
bit softer judgment of myself it's like
okay no one's gonna see the first five
takes that I butchered you know as long
as you get it at the end that's all that
really matters so for anyone that's like
kind of on the fence or has tried and
struggled like I can't do this I would
say just like just continue to push on
because it gets a little bit easier and
then you also just learn to not judge
yourself so harshly yeah it's it's it's
never as horrible because I think I
think I know a lot of people have this
and I have this too when you like hear
your own voice or see your own face it's
terrible like if you then if you go and
look at your own video or try to edit it
you're like ah sounds terrible and and
this looks terrible and you're grinning
you grin is terrible
yeah it's never as bad for other people
just you know anyone starting out that's
everyone has that everyone looks at
themselves and goes like ah but I'm not
necessarily against scripts I think if
if the point where you notice it's
scripted maybe it's just a bad script I
don't know you know it's not a script
that is in
true but if you have if you have a
natural script there can be there can be
value if you want to be really precise I
think a lot of so I'm I'm like the
opposite of of maybe Tim because Tim you
make like very very high quality videos
with lots of takes and lots of edits and
I just sit down and I just do a single
take and like I have 50 billion in there
and and mmm let me think about this
and and then yeah just I just don't you
just have to not care I guess I know but
the thing is I mean yonyx got loads more
subscribers and his content is loads
better and the reason is quite simple a
couple of times I went to see a public
speaking coach and he said to me that
the arts is making everything seem like
a fresh thought making it seem like it's
just come into my mind and it's rolling
off my tongue if if in feels
stage-managed of course I think if you
get really good at this you you can
actually structure it quite a lot of
people won't realize but if people can
sense that there's a structure to it and
it's not it's not a genuine freshwater I
think it doesn't come off quite as well
well the subscribers I like have a
different opinion maybe it's just
because I upload more at the moment so
what's amazing about your content is you
do it in one take and it's clearly just
coming from your brain and it's just a
beautiful stream of consciousness and if
it were me of course I would go back and
I would get rid of the cops and the
Yun's and so on but in a way that makes
it even more genuine and authentic that
you don't do that yes I I actually went
in looked I it wasn't a super thorough
analysis but I got a bunch of channels
kind of relevant to our space and I
looked at their upload frequency and
their age and their number of
subscribers and all that stuff and and
looked at some distributions and I was
really surprised that upload frequency
wasn't that highly correlated with the
rate of subscribership so because I was
sort of
upon myself about my frequency of
uploading cuz it's just so hard with the
way I'm doing this I like man I need to
like change the way I do this because
I'm never gonna be able to put out more
than like once a month so Yannick I I
think you should give yourself a little
bit more credit it the volume of course
is something good with it but I think I
originally over indexed on the thinking
about making really high quality visuals
I think what people most care about is
high quality information and if you can
do that with high quality visuals that's
great and then all the more reason to
watch it but if you have a bunch of
fluff but not much content I don't think
you'll make it yeah that's true and I
think the person person ability as well
and I think some of the most successful
youtubers have a real character and real
ease with the camera and with their
audience and there's a sense that
they're invited to the party you're kind
of inviting people into this experience
do you learn yeah I definitely think
it's learn about like the more you prep
it out the more comfortable you become
with it but I actually have an
alternative alternative hypothesis with
this I think the more you upload is
better like if you can manage it you
know like once you the step 1 is be
consistent over a long period of time
like if you've been doing it for say 4
to 6 months then I think it's like turn
it up and let as much flow out of it as
you can and as you can manage
it's like managing yourself more so it
might be one of those things that if
your content is good then there's a
multiplicative relationship with your
upload frequency well every every one
every one that is a bit advanced they
always say consistency right it's never
that much frequency I agree it's more
like consistency and and I I would want
to make more high-quality videos and
fewer of them but I'm just too lazy
honestly like I can't forget my edit
stuff it's like I like I did me me
review right to it together with my
friend Antonio and that took me like a
month to edit it's it's so dumb but it's
I'm so lazy yeah I think one of the
things that is good on your video
janek as well is it's a little bit like
listening to a Sam Harris podcast as in
you have quite a relaxing calming voice
and you you kind of you place people in
a warm comfortable space and and the
other thing is is you are very good at
saying well basically what this means is
this so you're saying that the reason
they did this is this we're going to be
talking about contrast applause and a
little oh and I was just reading the
paper I think you know the face net
paper on the Triplett loss and they
never really explained why the margin
parameter was there and you just say
well the reason they put the margin
parameters is just because of this and
people were like oh okay no idea that
was the reason so I think providing
intuitions and providing that kind of
expert commentary in context I think is
super valuable yeah I I was I was
thinking for a while about the space
here and I mean they're not that many
let's say youtubers in in really the
space of their there are some in the
space of AI right but it really in the
space of a a I research there there
really aren't aren't that many and I
appreciate a lot that we all will make
different styles of content which I find
really really cool so yeah I wouldn't
like even though I said we want to make
higher quality content I think and you
know that you you already do that and
and I appreciate like everyone has their
own style and I think that's cool I
think we should never converge on the
same style or something we don't want to
be like 10 channels that do the same
thing because even now when we do the
same papers you know you get foreign or
work with us for you get for entirely
different views on the same thing and
and entirely different takes and I think
that's awesome so my question to you was
what what is kind of the most you might
be reading your comments and stuff what
is the most criticism that you get like
the most frequent NAG that people have
with your with your channels I've been
really lucky in that I don't have many
people watching my videos I guess so the
percentage of people that complain is
very low
I I can only think of one or two and
they were so innocuous that nothing has
bothered me but you guys may have had
just a higher volume yeah I used to get
upset about it but now I just take the
criticism and I don't think we've had
anything that bad actually someone
emailed me over there was something I
said that wasn't inclusive which really
made me it really challenged me to be
more careful about how how I say things
and on the m/l read it sometimes we
don't get past the gatekeepers on there
but you know it's fairly fairly
innocuous to the owners yeah I find the
the the community in general is super
friendly on YouTube at least that's
that's also my experience it's it's
amazing the comments are mostly positive
and I appreciate all the comments and
yeah because I just hear other youtubers
say like oh how the comment sections and
maybe we're just in a really lucky
subfield that we're where people are
just interested in the in the content I
think I think that's awesome yeah by far
the highest frequency comment I get is
something along the lines of thank you
and keep doing what you're doing and it
really helped me understand or something
like that so almost every comment I get
is something that makes me want to do it
more I think if I was getting criticized
a lot I probably wouldn't still be
making content it would just be too much
mental burden to overcome so I think
we're lucky in that respect amazing it
was the bootstrap Layton I just like
yeah with me I get a lot of comments
where it's like either somebody presents
their idea and then I have to like think
about it you know what I mean or it's
like could you explain more at 5:46 or
whatever and so for me answering
comments sometimes it can almost feel
like a whole like two-hour block in my
day because it's the machine learning
subfield where these comments are like
things you have to think about it's not
like something that you can quickly so
yeah yeah what what is a bit what is a
bit how should I say special is that
usually what gets the most attention is
when I do like news or
drama or something which I feel it's you
know I I make a video about it just
because I want to say what's happening
and so on but yeah I definitely gets
more attention than just the paper
videos and but what I was really
positively surprised by is I made a
video about how I read a paper and I
thought I didn't really thought think
much of it but many people asked me for
it like how do you read papers and I'm
like I don't have a special method I
just start at the top and I read it and
okay and that and that was received
fairly positively so I think there's a
lot of lot of stuff still to do and in
all of this I think the criticism
criticism I get the criticism I get the
most is whenever I like do some weird
sounds or my laptop fan just I like I
have this old tablet where I record the
stuff that fan is just booming because
of the screen recording and there I
guess the requests I get the most is to
write code for these papers but I mean
that's for a lot of these papers it's
just a lot of work right and and that's
that's what you realize when you know
you're trying to sit down and then you
first of all you do two hours of
plumbing to get the data set in the
correct whatnot and then you can maybe
get the method to run and then you have
to wait like what like a machine
learning coding videos like okay I'm
gonna coat this okay and now we'll train
the model there's like come here for 30
minutes so you have to do it like over
multiple days and stuff yeah actually
something weird happened to me I was
gonna make a video about oh I had this
really really dumb idea that you know
it's probably not gonna work but I'll
just make a video about how I would go
about implementing a research idea right
so I sat down encoded bla bla bla bla
bla bla and then I let it run and then
it actually worked
oh crap interesting yeah
so that's I hope that's a video that I
can get out soon because yeah so maybe
your thoughts on this as well because my
so my original reason for starting my
channel personally and I really want to
hear from you as well but my original
idea was just I thought it would just
help me understand papers better as you
said initially like I thought okay I'm
gonna read papers anyway so I might as
well make a video about them right so
others can understand it too and if you
know 20 people watch me I have
accountability to not basically lie to
20 people about what is in the paper so
I must understand it and especially yeah
these early papers with like that but
but eventually it dawned on me that you
you could do actual research in this
manner where you just really open about
what you do when do you make this as a
video and not only complete work because
right now everyone's sitting in their
box or with their little team right and
they're like huh and then once they have
all the results they're like archive
here we are alright this is new and it
is so different to how we do things for
example in software engineering where
we're you know people go and get up and
they're like here is like my initial
whatnot and then people see it sometimes
they comment on it and stuff I want to
see research going to much more in a
direction like that and I believe that
for example YouTube or things like this
is a great place of doing this where you
you don't have to actually film yourself
coding but it could just be like hey I
have this project here's what see here
is my intermediate work my intermediate
results right and you know just let
people comment on it and stuff
I don't know what do you what do you
think about kind of a future like that
yeah that's really fascinating I'm I'm
not super deep into the world of
publishing papers so I don't know if I
have a great perspective on that but
what I will say is I've one of my
ongoing annoyances I think whether it's
well-founded or not
is it seems like when I read a paper
similar to Tim's comment before it's
like why aren't they just saying it in
English exactly what is going on here
and I realize the peer review process
requires some level formalism and and
that's good in a lot of cases but it
seems like there's this big vacuum
between people that are trying to learn
and then like the information and then
it's not presented in this pedagogical
way right it's presented in this way of
like a scientific defense or whatever
but for someone who's not already at the
the edge of that field it's just really
daunting and I found that whenever I
enter a new field because like you know
again my my history is in physics and
stuff whenever you start reading a paper
it's just such a struggle because every
section there's so much jargon and it's
not really until you read dozens or even
100 papers that you can pick up another
paper and then pretty comfortable
reading through it and I think that's a
blocker for a lot of people that would
like to be introduced to some of the
cutting-edge research but they just
aren't willing to invest that amount of
effort and then still not really get
this reward when they finish the paper
so I think there's a lot of value people
like us can add that are familiar enough
that they can say alright this stuff you
can ignore and then the core of this
thing I'm going to explain in a mostly
pedagogical English way so that's kind
of my motivation for writing and making
confidence like let's just take all this
formalism out for a minute and maybe
we'll return to it because it's
interesting but if you just want to
understand what's going on here so we're
about to get into bootstrap your own
Layton and throughout the pipe the paper
they're constantly comparing it with Sim
CLR and it's like there is no diagram of
Sim CLR in the paper or there's no
discretion of it it's just direct
comparison with this thing that you
probably haven't read if you like brand
new to it
exactly it's easy to think that these
authors are actually being elitist and
sometimes they are there's a paper
called troubling trends in ml
scholarship whereas talks about math
enos in order to get something published
you need to have grits you
mathematical formulas but based on the
papers I've read I see the opposite
actually they're trying to be as clear
as they can the problem is they are so
deep into this one topic they just don't
even know what it's like to not know
what's in CLR is or to not know what
this particular thing is so the the real
value proposition there is to be able to
articulate this in a way that most
people can understand because if you're
just a layman reading through these
papers there will be so many blockers
there'll be so many concepts that you
won't understand and it will just stop
you from being able to make progress
reading the paper yeah the academic
writers too you know that's not their
job it's to take that on I'm just saying
that that leaves a gap and people like
us can try to fill it I don't think
they're doing anything wrong or I'm not
accusing them of being elitist or
anything because they're doing a very
specific job and the peer review process
for all its strengths and weaknesses is
there and they need to play that game
and they play very well
but it does leave the gap I think well
shall we move on to the contrasted
learning and bring your own late and I
wanted to give just like a very quick
introduction to the topic I did a video
on my youtube channel with Eric crime
most recently talking about the
quadruplet law so some of this is in my
mind but at some point this concept of
contrastive learning was invented and
the idea is is that you typically have
an encoder and you want to learn a
representation which has this behavior
so if you have a 7 going in and a 2
going in you want them to be projected
into the embedding space far apart from
each other and typically these things
are a treat achieved with Siamese
Network so you have two encoders but the
weights are shared between the two
encoders and then you have a loss
function and the loss function is this
contrasted loss so if you have here two
zeros you would expect them to be
projected into the same space in a seven
and a two very very far apart so far so
good now the contrasted loss is very
very similar to the softmax and it's a
function of the simmer
garetty between the pair of images that
you're interested in and there's a
temperature parameter as well kind of
divided by all of the similarities
between one image and all of the other
images so there is some variations on
the contrast of loss this is where it
starts to get quite interesting isn't it
so that the face net paper introduced
this concept of the triplet loss and the
triplet loss was when you had an anchor
a positive and a negative and as you can
see here the distance here is a function
of I is the anchor and J is the positive
and K is the negative so it's a function
of the distance squared between the
anchor and the positive take away the
anchor in the negative plus a margin
parameter alpha now you can see this is
all starting to get quite esoteric and
it gets even worse than this but the
idea is is that you want to have a
clustering behavior that kind of
improves the you know makes tighter
clusters so the the intraclass
similarity is it's closer in the inter
class distance is further so that's why
there's been so much research on
different types of contrasted loss and
then these folks introduced something
called the quadruplet loss which
introduced metric learning on that
objective so in the quadruplet loss
rather than just having the yank of the
positive and the negative you have a
second negative in it it models a second
push between the two negatives and
inside the loss function instead of
using distances we're now using a metric
network which is learned and there are
now two alpha parameters and you can
just see how hacky this gets and on this
video with eric rhymers he implemented
this and it produced worst even worse
results than the Triplett loss and when
you are doing this negative sampling as
well you you need to come up with a
mining strategy that will find hard
sample basically you want to find really
really difficult examples that will make
the algorithm converge as quickly as
possible
now just bring your own latent paper it
does a wonderful thing as it just
completely dispatches with the need to
have negative sampling I hand over to
you guys for the description well it's a
it's a bit it's a bit of magic right
because what you're saying with the with
the original any sort of contrastive
losses that
things that are things that I know
should be similar they should be closed
in the in the latent space and things
that I know should be not similar they
should be far apart so now you leave
away this far apart thing you only have
things that I know should be similar
they must be similar in late in space so
there is technically nothing that keeps
the network from from just putting
everything together right because if
everything's similar certainly things
that are supposed to be similar or
similar and I think that's the the
surprising novelty of that paper is the
is the fact that it it precisely doesn't
converge to these bad situations
actually works and that's yeah it's sort
of a bit of magic and I've had people
people in the comments were very helpful
when I made a video about this trying to
reason why this could happen but I'm not
entirely convinced yet yeah but there's
yeah it's definitely cool I guess I'm
kind of sold on like the moving average
target encoder being different like it's
not like a Siamese network where we're
sharing waste on both sides we have this
kind of moving average on the target
side so I think maybe that's what
regularizes it I mean yeah like I
watched your video and I was like yeah
they should just map it to a constant
representation it's like amazing that it
doesn't do that but so I think maybe
it's the moving target paired with the
data augmentation or something like that
has to be one of those - right the
nature augmentation seems capably pause
and give a brief overview of what the
implementation is of bring blue strap
you're on Layton yeah how did you sit
Zak okay so there's a network that they
call the online network and then a
network that they call the target
network and the idea is you only have
positive pairs and the online network is
trying to output the prediction of what
the target network is going to generate
and so in the first case they'll take an
image and they'll add some sort of
augmentation to it some manipulation of
it and that's the online networks job is
to predict
a different or the same image but with a
different augmentation what that will be
output for the target so you're sort of
trying to find some kind of invariance
situation where you're manipulating the
same image in two different ways and
then using in one network to predict
what the output of the other network
will be and then of course there's this
trick of instead of having two totally
separate networks I'm going to make both
the networks essentially the same but
one has a set of weights and the other
one is the moving average of those
weights from previous gradient updates
so it seems very strange on the surface
and I guess it is but I think in essence
they're trying to avoid the weird
artifacts that come from using
contrastive loss and just the notion I
think is kind of weird that you're going
to learn something by comparing it
against randomness because in some sense
it makes sense that okay here's positive
pairs and here's negative pairs that
learn the difference but on the other
hand it could be a kind of trivial task
and as you mentioned Tim it's odd
there's some skill and engineering and
coming up with the right samples the
right negative samples to put in if you
want to have any hope of actually
learning something so I think the noise
contrastive estimation paper prove the
convergence properties of this sort of
approach but of course that's with like
infinite data and if in a time and in
the real world you you need something
less than infinity to work with and then
it comes down to all these tricks of
ichael how do you actually sample from
the noise distribution so that you have
efficient learning and then I think one
particular example in this set of papers
they were talking about the sim cor as a
baseline what was interesting there was
they found that they had to add in this
color augmentation so they would like
randomly perturb the color makeup and
they said the reason they had to do that
is because when they took a a random
crop of an image that the model could
essentially learn to just map the color
histograms because random crops at the
same image had matching histograms so
the model you know found this shortcut
though I don't actually have to learn a
great representation I can just look at
the color histogram so that to me that's
a great example of the type of behavior
you get that you don't want that's just
an artifact of this negative sampling
thing so now they're having to engineer
these creative ways to get around it so
if you can instead just not do that and
that's a set of problems you don't have
to try to engineer a way around yeah
it's it stands to reason that getting
rid of the negative samples is a good
thing especially with the triplet loss
there's a combinatorial explosion of
possible you know triplets that you
could select and it's just really really
difficult and I think one of the lessons
that we've learned say with denoising
auto-encoders is that what you really
need to do is find examples that are on
the manifold and off the manifold it
doesn't necessarily need to come from
anywhere but I'm trying to develop
intuition on what are the key things
about this paper that makes it work that
the really important thing seems to be
the data augmentations and that is kind
of that idea of just pushing an example
off the manifold so rather than needing
to find a negative which is normally
uniformly selected from the training set
let's just make some kind of
modification to push it off the manifold
the other thing is this moko thing I
hope maybe you guys can give me some
intuition here but you have you have
this Siamese networker you only update
the weights on the top one and then the
weights on the second one it's the
exponentially weighted moving average
but you don't update that and then you
have the two representations that come
out and you build another network to
kind of predict one from the other so if
you were to deconstruct that where is
most of the value in that configuration
I just wanted to talk a little more
about the data augmentation and when Zak
was talking about the color histogram
augmentation avoids that one shortcut so
then get like it's so interesting
talking about these data augmentations
here's one paper try zooming on this
this is Adam attic shortcut removal for
self supervised representation learning
where they have this parametric function
that learns how to corrupt the image
address it in an adversarial way to
avoid these shortcuts so it's like the
color histogram thing is intuitive to us
that we can come up with that
augmentation but how do we kind of
search for these augmentations is
something that I think
really interesting because we don't know
all the shortcuts it might take but how
do how do they find the shortcuts well
what they do is they have like an
adversarial search so the adversary is
going to put the image to some it's like
this idea of like differentiable data
augmentation because rotation or
flipping the images it's still just an f
of X on our image and so we're applying
some transformation to it so why not
just parameterize it so I've seen
another take on this idea of
parameterizing the data augment which
one is this okay so this one is they're
going to take the image and put it
through some kind of neural network to
augment the image so they have these two
images and they create new data images
by having this idea of differentiable
augmentation so it's like are we going
to be hand designing these augmentations
or how do we get away from hand
designing these augmentations as
something that I think is super
interesting super powerful so for
something like these contrast of methods
that as Tim mentioned is there are only
two it has to be either data
augmentation or maybe something with
this momentum update of the target
Network right but I think it's more
likely that the data augmentation is the
workhorse in this well we we know that
from the paper they do a full ablation
of the momentum thing right they because
they have a table in there where they
fully where they just say okay we did we
do stop gradient of the honor so both
our networks are just the same but we
only train one but we always copy the
parameters over it's not a moving
average and that just doesn't work with
their method like accuracy of zero and
so you might you might make the case but
then also the augmentations it hurts
when you take them away now they claim
it doesn't hurt as much as in like sim
clr but still and they don't have a full
ablation so they go baseline remove
grayscale remove color crop and blur
only and then crop only and I think a
lot of papers show that especially the
random crop is such a big is such a big
workhorse of these methods it would be
have been nice to see here what happens
if they don't do any augmentation at all
and
just do this just do this moving average
thing I yeah I wonder about this idea of
so again I'm not like deep into this
part of the literature but why are they
kind of not trying to encode the
augmentation itself as part of this for
instance why not have a an output of the
network that's trying to predict the
actual augmentation procedure and then
use that so that that's part of the
understanding of the network because
when I think about how we imagine things
we could reason about this is the same
thing as that because I can understand
what transformation would need to be
applied and there's some sorts of
transformations that are going to make
this object unrecognizable from this
other object and being able to kind of
internalize that intuition seems to me
valuable but I haven't seen anything in
these references to do that are you guys
aware of anything that what does do
something like that well the first the
first batch of self supervised learning
papers they were doing something similar
were they for example they turned the
image in one of four directions and then
the network actually had to predict the
rotation that happened at the beginning
and that made the net that was the
objective
it wasn't like a contrastive loss or
anything it was a classification to
explicitly understand which augmentation
was used but I'm always very skeptical
of these like let's learn Ockman tations
and so on because ultimately what we're
doing with augmentations is we say we
know that this particular transformation
does not change the nature of the image
and an algorithm like a a a CNN or
something like this just can't make that
determination there are many many things
that actually change so if if like we're
talking about street signs and reading
street signs or it's actually write a
flip is not the coolest thing you can do
right like is it one way this way or
this way it's it's different
so it's it's not
like we as humans understand you
shouldn't do a flip right there and I'm
very doubtful that augmentation like
automatic augmentations or adversarial
augmentations can do much in that space
because like so in terms of adversarial
examples there are so many of them that
okay the ones you're gonna find are
going to be valid but they're not nearly
all of them they're not nearly that and
they're only going to be one particular
class of them it's very limited a couple
of thoughts about this because the first
thing is there are some network
architectures that the work from Kohan
and Welland for example is about
creating let's say steerable cnn's so
that's almost encoding the augmentations
into the architecture as an inductive
prior so what they do is they'll take
the the CNN filters and they'll
automatically rotate them 90 degrees and
180 degrees to give it that kind of
invariance to rotations in the input
space and what we're talking about here
is kind of like the same thing in
Reverse we're just going to augment the
data itself so that's not a prior that's
experienced so what we're doing is is
either by increased experience or
increased priors we're helping learn
something which is still semantics
because it doesn't matter whether the
dog is brown or blue what rotate it
semantically it's still a dog and we're
trying to trick the algorithms into
believing so we were just talking about
metric learning and I know Jannik was
talking on this as well would it be
possible to do augmentation learning but
it reminded me a bit of Sciales priors
you know he's he's saying okay we should
just figure out all of the human priors
and we should just hard code them in and
that presupposes that all of the
relevant you know Oldman tations or
transformations could be analytically
enumerated so would it make sense to
learn the augmentations using a separate
network well if you learn this here's
the thing if you learn augmentations
instead of hard-coding them you have
hard-coded something else so if you
learn the augmentation using like an
adversarial example generator you know
adversarial examples they have a loss
function
they have a constraint so an adversarial
example in images it's usually you're
not allowed to go away more than eight
out of 255 units of color from the
original image and so there there's our
prior again our human prior that says
visually two images are similar if they
deviate by not more than this so I I
think maybe it's easier to specify the
adversarial constraints or the
constraints on the learning procedure
but at some point you have like I've not
seen a formulation yet we're not in one
way or another you come in and tell
implicitly or explicitly what a valid
and invalid augmentation is so um I'm
skeptical on the whole let's learn
augmentations thing I think what bugs me
a little bit about this the intuition of
the setup is that it's not necessarily
true that this is the same as that thing
and and there's degrees of sameness
right so with this contrast of learning
you're saying okay these are the same
I'm gonna give it a 1 or / 0 however and
these are difference I'm going to give
it the other label but really it's a
matter of degree right it's like it you
could imagine warping it in in
particular ways and maybe semantically
we think it's the same thing but it's a
heavily distorted version and there
seems to not necessarily be that that
notion there so it seems like if you
could encode the augmentation in some
meaningful way and and learn that and
use that as a prediction task they they
could use that to their advantage and
the efficiency of learning of like ok
yeah these are semantically similar but
they're wildly distorted or very close
and and the degree to which you're off
could power the gradient in the updates
but should the augmentations be
anthropocentric or should they be kind
of weird computer did you see what I
mean because yeah human beings we have
very human distortions and things that
we understand but if you look at these
augmentations they're the kind of things
that you know that computers would
understand yeah totally like this is
paper the automatic shortcut removal you
see the way it changes the image is just
noise it's like generative teach
networks or the synthetic petri dish
they if you let the neural networks
produce their own data they produce some
kind of high-frequency thing like this
that we can't even interpret but I'm
like I still think that it one paper
that I really like is Jeff Clunes AI
generating algorithms where he's talking
about how we're gonna automate the
search for these building blocks so like
to Yonex point on we have these building
blocks of rotations flips cropping so
how do we find these building blocks and
I think that we have these kind of
adversarial or meta-learning outer loop
inner loop optimizations that can put in
the place to learn the building blocks
but then on Zach's side too I'm really
interested in this idea of yeah can we
uncover the augmentation like this paper
self supervised gans the discriminator
has to do these two tasks it has to do
real over fake and it also has to
predict the angle of rotation but I so
this kind of thing of multitask learning
also recover the augmentation it adds
more structure I think to the overall
framework in which we can inject more
learning algorithms and then it's like
like T Onix point we're skeptical about
can we really learn these augmentations
but I think if you design this framework
where it's uncovering the augmentation
it has this adversarial component I
think you can put this in there if that
was any sense yeah I mean it's it's
entirely possible because we used to we
used to handcraft features right it may
be it's sort of the same the same issue
again we used to handcraft features from
machine learning and then but a boom
deep learning right and people back that
like me back then would have said where
there's no where you have to have valid
features Rob inaudible ah but
nevertheless deep learning comes and for
some reason it's extremely effective at
parsing out good visually meaningful
features and okay I mean the same thing
could happen for for augmentations
absolutely the elephant in the room
though is that we are wasting the
representational capacity of these
networks because we're learning the same
thing many different ways or you could
argue it the other way maybe all of
these augmentations are helping us learn
one data manifold and it's not as
inefficient as we thought because you
know you can
you can take the lottery ticket a
hypothesis way of looking at it which is
the networks are actually very efficient
you know we just need the
parameterization to help them train or
you could take the other viewpoint which
is that they're incredibly inefficient
and we're learning the same thing in
myriad of different ways so which is it
I think if data argumentation is just
being contrasted learning with more
priors it's like the same idea right
like we're still yeah it's just an F of
X of the X yeah that's not really the
prior is like that you say all the
augmentations should actually lead to
the same thing by choosing these
augmentations it basically encodes the
knowledge of what in variances we expect
from the images so yeah and you can see
that very very well in this bootstrap
your own latent paper in the
architecture because the the online
network you it's special because you
don't want the two outputs of these
networks to be the same but you want to
take the output of the online network
and then have another little neural
network that predicts the output of the
target network so that that little
neural network has the task of how
what's the most likely representation of
an image that produced this
representation that I had here but with
an a different unknown augmentation
right and also it's not the same as me
but it's like ten steps behind me but
but it's technically it is idiot you're
asking it to unlearn these invariances
as you said and by doing that that so
this is very makes it very explicit that
what this is supposed to learn is the
what is what is the same across
everything across this image augmented
with all of these augmentations so yeah
we're basically putting lots and lots
and lots of priors in there and but what
what what part of the architecture
prevents the mode collapse
is it the mochou thing
probably but like their hypothesis like
it's pretty clear that it is a loss like
it is probably the global optimum if you
were to mode collapse like that that
seems pretty clear if you look at the
architecture if you if you were to start
at this everything goes to one place
point you would stay there right because
I mean I guess with a lot of noise you
could get out of it but this is the
optimal solution so it's probably a
combination of this moving average and
the fact that we just take little steps
in SGD so we you know it's it's much
easier to get into the basin of
Attraction where you have to make
sensible representation instead of going
to that degenerate situation I want to
connect it to two other really popular
ideas like knowledge distillation where
we have the teacher network distill the
class labels into the student network
and then on the other hand self-training
where we label some unlabeled data and
then train on those pseudo labels this
and this idea of this target network I
think are all connected it's all the
same idea of self training this a
momentum updating target network and
then knowledge distillation where I
guess you can use another neural network
to kind of bootstrap and UNCHR umple the
paper as we connective I see like ten
different papers coming out all all
doing like different versions of exactly
this instead of this instead of the moco
thing we use a distilled moco thing and
I guess that's our field every time
something new comes out then everyone
tries to combine it combinatoric lee
with all that came previously so I
expect this plus ganz expect this plus I
don't know really much everything
expected Asian versions of this yeah
yeah well when you read papers it seems
overwhelming doesn't it but actually as
you say it's a combinatorial
recombination of fairly good ideas that
work and when you see the structure of
these cool ideas it's not actually that
overwhelming is it yeah I've seen I've
seen I've heard of people doing things
because what you can do is
you know knowledge bases like Wikipedia
can parse knowledge graphs out of
Wikipedia and things like this and you
can get triples like Abraham Lincoln
born in a year and so on and a task in a
machine learning tasks in these systems
is to find links that aren't in the
knowledge base yet but they're very
likely and you sometimes do this with
like tensor decomposition methods or
things like this and i i've heard of
people doing this for papers so they
they see which kind of which ideas are
combined into new papers and then they
predict links where there is none yet
which means that this is a likely
combination of ideas that hasn't been
done yet so it might be nice if we put
something like this on the blockchain we
have like half half of our automated
scientist and then people just grab
ideas from there and try them through
yeah I had one more question on this
idea of the augmentation encoding thing
since you guys are so familiar with this
part of the literature so it seems to me
an understanding of oneness or entity
sort of implies an understanding of how
that thing will behave under
manipulation right so if I understand
that this is a dog I'm applying a
rotation I can kind of predict what that
will look like so are you familiar with
anything that takes for instance the
augmentation and the source image as
input and then has to predict the output
and then it's sort of like a
reconstruction loss in that sense so
you'd like encode the augmentation and
like say like a one hot encoded vector
and then condition it on integrated in
the forward pass yeah and then you know
maybe the rotation is a numeric value or
the amount of Gaussian blur or whatever
but yeah that's the input along with the
source image and then you have to
reconstruct the output because that
seems like a high fidelity high
dimensional signal too as opposed to a
zero one true not true thing yeah there
are a lot of these I mean this goes into
the direction of these info Gans and and
things like this and it's not
it's not explicitly the same but there
are a lot of architectures where you
kind of want some sort of steerability
in the generation of data right so I
guess you could take you could take that
because they're all these Gans where
it's like glasses on glasses off more
old person more young person and so on
and you can steer all of this with
disentangled latent things or even by
feeding these latent like you do a
conditional again where you feed these
these things in I guess you could
technically do an image to image
translator conditional on things like
this probably I guess it's been done it
seems within the reach of of the visible
but you mean you mean that this should
be maybe performed as a pre training
objective because we we can compute the
output right and maybe if we let the
image where the network predict generate
the output for us yeah why not yeah I
was just thinking about provide a
semantic understanding give it a better
chance of understanding these things
because it seems to me that the
augmentations are so coupled to an
understanding of these entities that you
would what that jointly but it sort of a
hypothesis as an outsider so I just
wanted to bounce it off you guys my
opinion is that as a pre training task
envision you don't want to go into the
pixel space because like even image GPT
gave the pixel space free training ago
with 6.8 billion parameters and it still
isn't as good as these blatant space
models so that would be my criticism
with like the cycle Gann imaged image
translation pre training task is like
it's like the denoising auto-encoder and
vision if you're reconstructing it in
the pixel space and then some kind of
lost in that high dimensional output
that I think that's like you're gonna
need a giant model for that I'd well you
could also I know we're gonna talk about
knowledge graph soon but one of the
things they try to do is put the node
embeddings and the and the edge
embeddings in the same space in a linear
space so that then you can do a semantic
sort of math with them where you say
like
source node plus edge equals destination
node so you have like this vector
triangle situation so I wonder if you
could sort of do that in this image
space where you encode both the source
image and the one after the thing was
applied to it and then you sort of pass
in the encoding and try to predict the
representation of the modified image as
opposed to the pixel space i I think the
the the issue here is that most of these
augmentations or all of these
augmentations are agnostic to the
content of the image right so it like in
in a if you turn off the brightness
it's it's like you just have to go to
through each pixel and up the brightness
so you know like with usually with these
pre training objectives you're trying to
make the network learn something about
the semantics of an image right if you
random cropping to things and then you
ask is this the same it somehow has to
learn to connect different regions of of
the image and so on and I I fear that
something like this where you simply say
how would this look after I turn up the
brightness the the network isn't like it
can basically ignore the input right you
can just residual connection the input
to the output and then in the last layer
add on top something like this now this
might change if you once you introduce
or flips and whatnot but ideally you'd
have some a pre training objective that
is somehow dependent on or different
depending on what's in the actual image
but I also don't think the ones today
are necessarily doing that yeah I
thought about this idea to like here's
my take on it say you had a semantic
segmentation model that's now labeled
mmm
let's labeled every pixel in the image
so we have like this green outline over
the car and we want to just change those
green pixels into truck and leave
everything else in the image as it is
like the sky the fire hydrant or
whatever so like what do you think about
that kind of pipeline a semantic
segmentation model first breaks it down
into the objects and then let me just
take like the cat highlight and try to
turn that into a dog
what in an unsupervised way like hat
well maybe you you could still use like
a pre trained semantic segmentation
model I I'm I'm I just know well in my
lab I actually know someone that does
things like this where you but this is
all done in supervised fashions right
where you have the masks and then you
try to change these only the mask pixels
into other classes and so on so that
exists but not necessarily as a pre
training task I guess so you'd have to
formulate somehow what information you
need and well what about as a data
augmentation like instead of rotation we
have semantic manipulation hi Paul Sybil
I think it gets into our discussion of
Leo Schwab NGOs talk where we want to do
this kind of like we want this
representation where it's like we can
just like extend the length of the dog's
head or you know put a different color
on Jax's fur or something yeah well I
think this brings us to our to our next
topic just to set the structure a little
bit limited on time so I want to talk
about graphs and and also fraud and auto
ml because I know these are things that
and as I could super interested in on
this subject of graphs this is kind of
like what Connor was just saying right
that there is something magical about
graphs in the fraud scenario you kid
model credit cards and accounts and IP
addresses and you can model how those
things are related to each other because
one of the problems we have with machine
learning is fidelity it's incredibly
good for pattern recognition over lots
of numbers but in the real world we have
Sydney you know symbols and we have kind
of graphs that meant you know that that
objects relate to each other so there's
a whole class of methods around this I
wanted to just quickly share my screen
and talk about this recent paper which
is called a retrospective on knowledge
graphs now there always seems to be a
tug-of-war in the machine learning world
we used to use knowledge graphs about 20
years ago and they had problems they
were brittle they typically needed to be
maintained
by human beings it was really difficult
to maintain the data consistency between
them and there's a whole sphere of
algorithms just for doing all of the
various different things to manage
knowledge graphs whether it's logical
inference relation extraction entity
linking you know entity recognition and
so on but the amazing thing is once you
have a knowledge graph certain things
like question and answering become
really really easy or high-level
reasoning becomes really really easy
because everything has been explicitly
captured but this paper goes on to
suggest that there aren't many knowledge
graphs in existence and the reason for
that is they're so difficult to maintain
and and find so I think there's a list
here at the bottom which says that there
are only about 20 knowledge graphs in
existence that's a bold claim I remember
one of course Satori I used to work at
Microsoft so that's the one that they
use of course there's one at Facebook
and Google has one there's a company
called cycle I know they've been
maintaining their ones it's about 1984
but you can almost count on two hands
that the amount of knowledge graphs they
are and it's just because they're so
difficult to maintain so I kind of I
passed the buck over to you Zack tell us
about knowledge grasp well I'm not an
expert on knowledge graphs but let me
say we need to add one more to that list
because we Amazon or AWS just open
sourced a new knowledge graph and we
just did a talk about it a couple days
ago a live stream with one of the guys
that was involved with that project but
it's a drug repurposing knowledge graph
so they have a bunch of information
medical information about diseases about
protein interaction networks and gene
interaction networks and stuff that I
know nothing about other than drugs and
symptoms and all this stuff so basically
the work that they did was they found
these six or however many different raw
data sources that were in tabular form
and then they worked with experts to
create this knowledge graph and then
open sourced it and then they also did
some research of using representation
learning graph representation learning
in an unsupervised way
to try to figure out these are a link
prediction tasks using contrastive lost
essentially so they would have these
positive pairs of like this drug
inhibits this gene or you know all these
different relations types and things in
the graph and then they looked at the
link prediction task and then rank them
by how probable they were so these these
edges that don't actually exist in the
graph but have high probability of
existing and then they looked at
particular triples so you have basically
source node which is some entity and
then a relation type and the destination
node so for instance this drug inhibits
this gene or whatever and this gene is
associated with this disease or koban 19
for instance so what they did was they
look at this in particular for kovat 19
and surfaced the top however many drugs
that are were so these are drugs that
are already out there for treating other
diseases or symptoms or whatever and
they're trying to find well what are
some good candidates for doing trials to
treat koban 19 so it turned out that
when they looked at the top ones there
were several of them that are on the
short list of the 36 that are currently
being used in clinical trials so this
isn't like a rubber stamp on the process
to say that this is a great way of doing
it but it's it's an interesting research
direction and i think they're they're
continuing to work on expanding that
knowledge graph so right now i'm sure
we'll talk more about this whether you
have features associated with the
entities themselves or whether it's all
of the information is encoded in the
graph structure itself are different so
right now there's no features in the
graph but they're adding in additional
data sources that will make that
available and then that's really when
the graph neural network techniques
start to shine one thing that fascinates
me is how we can come up with decent
representations for graphs and it seems
to be related to the number of nodes we
have because if you use a an adjacency
matrix as a way of representing a graph
then of course you have that Quadra
SiC relations so you couldn't really use
that for situations where you have a lot
of nodes in your graph
but I do see methods like this used in a
few places for example in the you map
algorithm it learns a spectral embedding
which i think is just the eigenvectors
of the adjacency matrix and you were
just saying could I could I learn
relationships that should be there but
aren't there and perhaps you could do
that by first projecting it into you
know similar to how collaborative
filtering works so you can kind of use
matrix factorization and then multiply
them together again and it might fill in
the the links that are missing yeah so
my understanding is there's kind of
three big tasks that you can do with
with graphs one is graph classification
so that's where you're trying to take
the full graph and ascribe some sort of
class to it so for instance whether a
molecular structure is toxic or not or
you know so you're actually encoding the
connections between the atoms and the
molecule and stuff and and that
information is encoded in the graph so
that whole graph is then trying to be
classified as one thing or the other
another is like node classification so
now I have a graph but for each node I
want to ascribe some sort of label so we
talking about fraud earlier so let's say
I have this big graph where we have
entities like an account and they're
connected through all these various
things like whether they use the same
credit card or the same mailing address
or something like that and you then want
to assign fraud not fraud labels to
every node in the graph and then the
other is link prediction so that is more
structural that I have this graph and I
have some understanding of it but I
recognize that my graph isn't complete
and I would like to assign some score to
edges of whether they're anomalous and
perhaps that's weird like this person
has no reason to be connected to this
person so it might indicate like an
account takeover situation or something
like that or in like a Facebook sense
there should be a connection between
this person in this person because they
share a lot of the same friends and
therefore it's likely that they also
know each other so I'm going to suggest
that and then you can start thinking
about this
and how it can be applied to a huge
number of different application areas
because the graphs are just so generic
and if the trick is really how do I
represent my data as a graph because
some of them are kind of obvious like
social networks but I've seen other ones
where they'll take like log information
from a cloud stack for instance of like
you have all these different logs of all
these different services and you can
start creating these semantic statements
of this entity is talking to this IP
address or whatever you can create this
huge graph and do really interesting
things and in terms of like causal
analysis and learning of beddings and so
it really is the trick of how do I get
my data in a graph and structure the
learning problem and you can do it ton
of stuff there seems to be a trade-off
right because one one representation is
where you know in the adjacency matrix
you can only record the way things
relate to each other but you lose the
metadata about every single node I
watched your video about graph
convolutional in your network so is it
GCN's and what that does is it models it
like a densely connected neural network
but every single points in the inference
stage I think you go and find all of the
neighbors of this vertex and you kind of
average over all of the values so that
seems to give you a bit of a combination
where you can kind of use their
relationship information but still have
the rich metadata as well yeah it's a
and then back to the comment about is
sort of an art with how you design it so
one specific case is let's say you're
talking about a fraud network you some
of them are obvious connections like a
credit card number if they share that
it's such a high cardinality such a
specific thing that a someone that
shares the credit card number two
accounts that's a very strong connection
but then you might also look at
something like the email domain like
there's going to be a lot of people that
use gmail.com and maybe you want to
encode that as a connection in the graph
so that you can connect things that
otherwise wouldn't be connected so then
when you do this neighborhood
aggregation scheme you can collect a lot
of information on the other hand that's
not nearly as specific as I cred
card so you don't want to give that
necessarily equal treatment and maybe
instead you want to encode that as a
feature to the node in this vector
representation as opposed to encoding it
in the graph structure itself and it's
not obvious which one is going to work
better in advance so you might just have
to try it but there's a lot of options
is my point and it's not always clear
what to do
yeah it seems you could either transform
it into a machine learning problem or
you could transform it into a pure graph
problem and use social network analysis
type algorithms you know like between
cetera I mean one thing you could do is
you know based on the the metadata on
two nodes you could come up with some
distance function that took that into
account and then and then use a graph
algorithm I suppose it's worth lingering
on this for a second that topological
methods are really good for things like
fraud detection if you visualize that
graph of that person that that you get
these weird topologies don't you like
rings and shapes and structures that
perhaps should be obvious when you
visualize the graph that would be
completely lost if you modelled it as a
machine learning problem yeah if if you
think about how you might do that
without crafts it's like okay I know
that these two accounts share a credit
card number I'm probably not going to
one how to encode all of the credit card
numbers as a feature right that would be
kind of silly because they're almost
unique so then you've just way over
parameterize your model and for not much
good because it's not gonna generalize
super well to new accounts particularly
if you know they're fraud and you shut
them down and now you've put this credit
card number on a blacklist or something
so you could do that but it's not really
a great option for deploying a model
into production for actually catching
fraud so then you say okay well maybe
another way I could do it is I construct
this graph and then I do some
pre-processing as a feature engineering
exercise so for instance how many times
have I seen this credit card associated
with fraud and how many times have I
seen it associated with legitimate
accounts and you do that as like an
offline batch process and then you put
that those two features as just yet
another feature in your in your model or
you can do everything as a graph and
then do something simple like label
propagation where you know
you you seed everything with the labels
that you know and then they kind of send
their fraud not fraud signals along
their connections and that converges and
you use that but then the cool part
about the GCN's is allows you to
essentially do both at the same time so
it's sending messages across their
connections and allowing you to
aggregate that information but then at
the end of the day you have a vector for
every node and you pass that into a
dense neural network and get a
classification for that particular node
to me if there's this side of like graph
convolution Network and then like
transformers where transformers
represent the input as a bunch of nodes
that are connected to all the other
nodes and then you learn the weights of
the edges whereas in the graph
convolutional Network me the designer of
this graph data structure and get I'm
gonna say here are the edges and then
don't like zero on the edges to the
other nodes so I think graph
convolutional networks have this prior
on like the initialization of the
weights or other edges between nodes
compared to the transformer that learns
the you know the edges the edge
strengthens can set it to zero if it
wants to do that so can't we just use
transformers for graph data so
interestingly there's there's a precise
relation between I think it's the graph
attention Network g80 and you can cast
that as basically a more generic version
of transit so the transformer is a
special case of this network so there's
a very sort of deep connection between
graph methods and transformers that I
can't speak off an off-the-cuff
in detail about but I know the DGL is a
framework deep graph library that works
on top of things like pi torch and
tensor flow and is an AWS open source
project for doing these graph neural
network tasks and they have a tutorial
on their website that goes through this
connection so if anyone's interested in
seeing that I know it exists but so just
to give a short spiel on graphic tension
networks you're basically learning to
attend separately over your neighbors
and your attention coefficient is then
the weight that you want to apply to
that so in the example I gave where you
have credit card connections and email
domain can
actions it would idea ideally learned
that okay this is a email domain
connection so I should treat it with
less importance as something like a
credit card connection and then you can
learn that as part of the the task res
that's kind of a weakness of the vanilla
GCN's is it just gives all of its
neighbors averages them together and
doesn't pay any attention to the
relation type or anything like that but
then there's of course a huge number of
tweaks so the same authors Kiffin well
and came out with the relational GCN so
then there's a separate projection
matrix for each unique relation type so
then it can learn to discriminate
between those two different things so
I'm interested more in a bit of the
general fraud detection methods and I
was always wondering is it is it like
sort of a cat-and-mouse game where you
develop better fraud detection and then
the fraudsters develop better ways of
frauding and then again you develop
better or is there is there some sort of
a silver bullet on the horizon that you
work towards where is it is there like
you know is there nirvana to achieve
where you say well this is the method
that is not really for audible I would
be skeptical of that being the case but
I I can't confidently say that it's not
but to me that's what's so interesting
there's two really interesting parts of
fraud detection the first thing is what
you're describing which is you're in
this adversarial relationship with
someone who understands your systems and
is actively trying to break them and it
is very much cat-and-mouse and it's how
do I stay ahead of the game and how do I
come up with like the perfect more
robust thing and then that's when you
get into these interesting ideas of for
instance using Ganz to help fill in the
holes of what you haven't yet seen to
kind of simulate what a fraudster might
do but then making that work as a whole
of their story but it's a very
interesting intellectual exercise and
then we were talking before about
adversarial examples maybe there's
things there because these
Errol's as we all know that have these
linear assumptions have these holes in
them so there's like the security issue
at play as well so if you think about it
your model is directly exposed to
fraudsters as a black box because also
they have to do is try to register
account for instance if it's an account
registration model and they either get
blocked or they don't
so that can now go into their training
data set right and if they do that
enough times they can sort of create a
proxy of your production model and then
once they have a proxy of your
production model they can do all sorts
of things and get gradients and now it's
a white box model right and then they
can for instance do adversarial
techniques to find potential gaps in
that there's some interesting work that
shows that adverse ale examples that are
learned on one network those same
adverse Hale cereal examples can trick
totally different network architectures
you know that they're general eyes as
being adversarial so that's kind of
scary
as someone who's building these
production models and then exposing them
so anyway that that whole part of it is
super interesting the other part of it
is that a lot of the techniques that are
cool and we've already talked about they
seem mostly focused on images and
language and and speech but it seems
like a lot of those ideas work really
well in fraud but there's just not as
much attention so I think there's more
low-hanging fruit to do interesting
things in that context and to bring
those ideas over and then put them in
production as opposed to just writing a
paper and and that's kind of what I
think is cool I'm just thinking out loud
about some potential use cases here so
anti-money laundering comes up to the
forefront of the mind the banks I know
they hire thousands and thousands of
people to do this manually they would
love to have a way of doing this in an
automatic way but the problem is false
positives right you can't just block
loads of people from performing bank
transactions because the the user
experience would be so poor so it's it's
almost better to err on the side of let
people make transactions even though
they're likely to be fraudulent and the
adversarial nature is quite interesting
because lots of fraudsters might realize
that the daily banking limit on a
transaction is let's say 10,000 pounds
so they do it just below that limit yeah
I mean one of the things in banking is
that I always understood that fraud
detection models didn't need to be
explainable
whereas credit and risk compliance did
so you need you need to explain why you
can't get a credit card but you don't
need to explain why you thought
something was fraudulent but I would
have thought that you would want it to
be explainable because it would be awful
having a black box and not understanding
why something was flagged up so I know
you can't talk about what you do at work
I mean where would you kind of draw the
line no I definitely if there's the
regulatory requirements when you're
talking about like credit risk and stuff
like that of explained ability and so
there's not as far as I know regulatory
requirements around enforcing on for
instance fraudulent account creation
online but at the end of the day we're
sending our most organizations will send
the model decisions to a human
investigator to sign off on and that
human investigator then needs to make a
decision of whether they're going to
shut them down so unless the model is
just so completely confident that you
can automate some small percentage most
of the time it's hey I'm flagging this
high-risk thing and I want a person to
look at it and in that case explain
ability is really important because you
don't want to just say the score is 0.98
you want to say hey this person's or
this account appears to be risky because
of these things to give them a lead for
something to investigate and you also
want to be careful of the causal link of
reporting for instance a confidence
score because then the human might
attend to error of like Oh most the time
when I shut down accounts that have a
point nine eight it works out okay and I
don't get in trouble and just surfacing
that information can change the result
another interesting part of it is that
you mention false positives so we also
have this feedback mechanism of the
decisions our model makes and the labels
we get right because we're training our
model of course on our business labels
but if you shut down an account because
your
all said it was fraud and then you give
it the label of one as fraud you're sort
of bootstrapping this process right and
that could lead to obvious problems so
the way a lot of organizations get
around this is they'll say okay I need
to have some understanding of my false
positives so I'm going to let an account
go that I think is fraud that my model
is saying this is definitely fraud I'm
gonna let them go anyway
and I'm going to make sure that they
turn out to actually be fraud and if
they don't then I know that my models
wrong right but then there's a cost to
basically letting fraud go on your
platform so it's a really interesting
world and when you start thinking about
the causal implications of deploying
these things and making decisions based
on them but then also trying to keep
this clean data set to build a robust
model could you articulate how
challenging the problem is because one
way of looking at it is it's really easy
if you have facebook for example and you
wanted to cash that fraudulent I don't
know the fake accounts you you know
who's talking to who you have a graph of
IP addresses you know how many friends
they have you know that a normal account
has this on average this number of
interactions per day and this amount of
diversity and it seems to me easy to
figure out the difference between a real
person and a fake person so is it easy
or if it's not what are the challenges
yeah so if I think it's a question of
scale and it's also a question of
sophistication so talking about Facebook
which I don't have any inside
information on but just sort of using my
experience to think through it there's
going to be some class of things that
are kind of easy to find because they're
being a little bit sloppy but as you
mentioned about this arms race situation
that they get really really
sophisticated and that's one of the most
interesting things of the job for me is
to find just the extreme level
sophistication you know a lot of times
it's not just some guy somewhere it's
like a coordinated set of state actors
or something right it's like Russia or
you know not just some guy that's trying
to make
few bucks so I think there's a like a
large percentage of it is probably easy
to find but then there's some percentage
of it that's really sophisticated high
scale and hard to find and then there's
also a different population of people
that are not operating at large scale
but they're finding high-value things on
a small number and those are really hard
to find because they put a lot of effort
into appearing you know that they can
create an account and they can script it
to be automatic and build up a
reputation and then they can create a
network of accounts that all self linked
but now it looks like just a normal
friend group right and you don't know
that all of them are fake because none
of them do anything malicious and maybe
they do that for six months or a year
and build some credibility on this
network and then they you know it only
takes one to be able to do some serious
damage and then the fact that you catch
the other ones it's like who cares
again devil's advocate on that is we
used to have this in search engine
optimization
Google used to have a real problem with
link farms but it's not a problem
anymore and you have this propagation so
you only have to find that one of the
things is bad and then it you can kind
of propagate it so that's before I made
the mistake of assuming your adversary
was BOTS I mean it could just be groups
of human beings that are colluding
together and of course it's much harder
to find them but there is this thing
that if you do find some of them then
you kind of find all of them sure but
you know if if you find all of them but
they got a million dollars out of you it
was probably still worth their time and
then when they do it again like yeah
you'll find them eventually but when you
the label you're talking about
propagating assumes that basically
you've been defrauded and you found a
case of fraud and at that point it's too
late right the hard part is identifying
them and taking some sort of measure
before they train you is there is there
something that you're allowed to tell us
where you like thought like wow that's
really smart like where you discovered
something and you're like
okay that's you know genius well this is
a roadster this isn't something related
to what we found on inside the company
but this is just a new story I read
somewhere that I think indicates this if
there was like a JPEG image of I think
it was a Scarlett Johansson an actress
and somehow through ways I don't
understand they encoded information into
that image where when it was put into a
database it would open up this
particular command in sequel that would
allow you to run arbitrary machine code
and then like issue I guess sequel
statements or her data dumps so just by
getting this image into your data set if
you didn't have the proper protections
in place that it would exploit some
vulnerability and extract information so
things like that it's like it's so far
beyond what any reasonable engineer
would be expected to know because those
people are so specialized in security
vulnerabilities and stuff like that that
it it's almost an unfair advantage
because they have such specialized
knowledge you know I'm a guy that spends
all my time thinking about machine
learning or whatever but not necessarily
security vulnerabilities of you know all
the world out there of that and what to
me seems innocuous might be highly
malicious and it's hard to know that's
crazy
bringing it back to knowledge grass I'm
interested to know your opinion on this
I I think they are still relevant in
enterprise today let's imagine you need
to implement Enterprise Search you need
to have self-service bi and data science
you need to have knowledge stores in the
company and so on and the typical search
engine I mean if you're a Bing or a
Google what does it do well it has a it
has a full text index which is a kind of
reverse index and then it will
deconstruct your query and it will know
what you're searching for are you
searching for dogs or shopping items or
blah blah blah and if you are searching
for shopping items it might redirect
your query to some underlying semantic
store or you might ask how old is Obama
it would go to the knowledge graph and
all of this stuff is hidden
from you but there's a lot of complexity
there so how would you design this do
you think there should be one monolithic
knowledge graph in companies or do you
think we should have different semantics
dollars back how should it be designed
and maintained yeah that's a great
question I don't I don't think I am the
right guy to ask it to that I don't have
much experience operationalizing
knowledge graphs at scale so I don't
think I have a varied answer what do I
think it's an interesting architectural
problem because in in large companies
you have many many groups of people and
every single group is interested in
their particular type of semantic data
so this part of the business might be
interested in dogs and this part of the
business might be interested in trainers
and if you have one monolithic knowledge
graph then they can't all you know
independently ship you need to have a
kind of decoupling but then you have
this problem how do they both embed
their semantic information into the
search engine where do they make it
discoverable so it's yeah it's it's
really really difficult but there are
advantages to having knowledge graphs
like you can easily do question and
answering and you can do a bunch of
reasoning and high-level tasks but but
you've got to manually maintain the
knowledge graph and how do you store it
and how do you maintain it yeah I think
there are several companies that
basically make that promise right that
they can come in and they can tie
together your data stores and allow you
to discover things and make connections
that previously weren't possible right
but as you're alluding to inside real
organizations that have a history and
departments and bifurcations and
different management structures it's
really really hard particularly in more
conservative organizations like banking
because of the regulatory environments
and all that that to get access to some
of these data stores is first of all
really difficult it might require
herculaneum effort to get alignment at
the top levels and to sell this idea yet
the other part is data quality that even
in some of the most sophisticated
organizations youth assume they're going
to have their ducks in a line when you
just write the sequel query to get the
data out but then you just find all
these problems and it's like no one
knows what this column means or where it
comes from or it makes these assumptions
and there's not data quality metrics
that are guarding this and
proactively raising flags so it could be
really hard I imagine to build a high
quality knowledge graph and to both
service that infrastructure and get all
the organizational things to lock in to
make it happen but if you could I
imagine there'd be tremendous value yeah
I suppose this is my assertion if you're
a Google or a Microsoft you you can do
it but I question whether it's even
within the reach of the average
corporation below that tier yeah I mean
even getting like the clickstream data
from the marketing department joined to
the fraud data or whatever I mean those
are usually entirely different
organizations with entirely different
management structures and data stores
and all that and like the primary key
between those things so that you could
join them together may not even exist
right because no one designed this
holistically but these are all sort of
bottom up systems that grew to serve a
particular function so integrating them
can be in practice just either
impossible or very difficult unless
you're kind of redoing it from scratch
indeed what do you think about the use
of graphs in machine learning I mean
Brit bringing it back to machine
learning we were talking about Yoshio
benzio and he has this kind of
consciousness prior which he calls it
and it's essentially a sparse factor
graph so you can have all of these
recombination of different things I
guess the question to you is do you
think that we need something like that
in machine learning or will it always be
magic and kind of implicit in in in the
deep learning model did do we need grass
I'm not familiar with that particular
work but I think there's a lot of
information and graphs that can't
efficiently be captured by the methods
I'm aware of anyway that for instance
you could you could always have imagined
a future engineering exercise to avoid
needing to use the graph explicitly in
the learning problem as we talked before
about my counting the number of frog
connections with a particular credit
card or something like that but then
there's always going to be these novel
signals inside the graph that your
feature intern engineering missed so it
could be that
yeah this credit card doesn't share any
but that credit card is linked to an
account that has this IP address that
links a bunch of other fraud accounts so
it's like two hops away or a different
relation type and then whatever rule you
came up with to quantify that it might
be totally blind to those sorts of
things whereas if you have an algorithm
that can operate on the graph itself and
and sort of fine tune the features
similar to out deep learning works on
images right it's like just give it the
thing and then it'll find the
representations that most make it able
to solve this task I think that's super
powerful and we're just starting to get
the tools that make that practical like
if you just think about the process of
doing a mini batch in a learning task
like this so if you have a one GCN layer
you need to get all of the neighbors of
every node so if you have a mini batch
of let's say 512 nodes and you need to
calculate its embedding well you don't
only just need to pull those 512 nodes
but you need to pull the neighbors of
those 512 nodes just to compute the
embedding which you then pass into the
downstream task but if you have two GC
and layers then you need the neighbors
of the neighbors so just creating that
mini batch you have to do this like
pretty exhaustive graph search and then
construct all these things and
coordinate do all the message passing
and that's not trivial and a lot of the
operations that deep learning frameworks
have optimized some of them aren't
represented in that way so we might need
new for instance kernel operations or
deep learning like the CUDA level or
whatever to make that work really well
and fast and we're starting to get there
but doing learning on big graphs before
wasn't really easy and it's just now
starting to become easier that begs
quite an interesting question whether
the time complexity is better to
pre-compute
a graph where you do you know you do the
label passing but you do some kind of
value passing versus do the mini-batches
on the graph convolutional network which
is faster well I
it's more a memory constraint that these
large graphs you can't fit in memory in
GPU memory all at once so how do you how
do you do it right it's like
computationally in memory it's so
expensive that you almost have to do
batching or you're very much limited in
the size of graph you can do so it's
like okay now I have to figure out
badging just so I can handle Facebook's
graph for instance and and I may not
even be able to fit that in a single
machine right so now I have a cluster of
GPUs and I need to coordinate and
segment them so that I'm not having all
this overhead between passing things
over the network right so it gets really
hairy pretty quick it's not as easy as
this image lives on this GPU and I get a
gradient update and I have a key value
store that coordinates the gradient
updates on which itself can be tricky
particularly if you have like sparse
representations and and graphs are
fairly sparse but it gets really tricky
when you have these insert dependencies
and the nodes that are in a particular
neighborhood should probably be on the
same partitioned and all that stuff
there we go let's finish off with
automated machine learning I know that
you were instrumental Amazon building
that out and one of the things that
worries me about auto auto ml is this
notion of black box thinking and machine
learning that we are and we keep talking
about democratization of AI and people
can just press a button and generate a
machine learning model is that dangerous
or is it revolutionary yes a dichotomy
it's like is it dangerous or is a
revolutionary I think there's a lot of
potential pitfalls in clicking a button
and not understanding what you're
getting particularly if the thing you're
interacting with has very little
understanding of the problem you're
trying to solve so if it a lot of the
auto email like open source things out
there it's like it doesn't know what
you're trying to do is just tabular data
and it figures out like the data types
of whether it's categorical or not and
there's
standard recipe of how to treat this and
then there's probably some either
ensemble Anor hyper parameter search or
something like that that combines a
bunch of stuff and tries to tune and get
the best model and that can be great
like if you're a data scientist and
you're trying to automate some piece of
your work I think that's a helpful tool
I don't think it's going to get you to a
place where someone who has no
understanding of machine learning can
click a button and generate a production
model but I think another way to solve
the problem is to design task specific
auto ml pipelines so for instance if you
have a a fraud detection auto ml
pipeline you can take a lot of that
prior knowledge of a fraud group you
have some semantic understanding of what
data you have so not just that this is a
categorical column but this is an IP
address associated with a sign in for
instance well then you can do a lot more
stuff right you you understand
semantically what's going on you
understand the task you understand what
types of features typically work and
then when you're doing these tuning
processes you can make some real
progress and I think that can work well
even if you don't if you're not a data
scientist but having that understanding
in context I think is what makes it work
well I mean what at what point does it
at what point does he kind of stop being
Auto ml and just is like okay you know
we we do some sort of a smart grid
search over a number of layers and and
learning rate and so on because the more
you know of a problem right the the more
constrained it becomes and ultimately
what you what you want to do with Auto
ml in that case is just emulate what a
data scientist would do and even even in
that like the data scientists have been
doing that exact same thing for the
longest time just not with neural
networks but with I don't know SPSS or
something load data right it figures out
what the columns are and then it does a
linear regression or a ANOVA test on it
and yeah it it it seems
although ml is this kind of this world
that a lot of people grow like use for a
lot of different things and in that case
I think it's it's pretty pretty smart
where you can say I know a lot about the
problem and I know that a data scientist
they would just do that would first find
the good architecture out of these
possibilities and then they would find
you know a good which features and then
it would find a good learning rate and
so on and and to automate that makes
makes a total sense seems to me but we
ought to to automate machine learning in
general it's sort of like you know
programming by just going to stack
overflow and copy pasting code it's like
oh how do I sort list ok copy paste and
then how do I do that and then you have
all these assumptions that the people
made or didn't make when they
constructed that code and you just
clubbed it together it seems like if you
do auto ml generically that's kind of
where you are you going it's certainly
true that there are a lot of repetitive
tasks that data scientists do you know
the in terms of normalizing the data and
encoding certain types of categorical
fields and and so on but I feel that the
emphasis on auto ml is on the wrong end
of the spectrum it's more on oh let's
choose a bunch of different algorithms
and see how they work and let's do a
bunch of different type of parameter
optimizations and especially we're
classical ml the only thing that matters
is designing good features I mean that
everything else is irrelevant
all of the algorithms are just slightly
different ways of kind of weighting the
features together and you know I give
the example of the telling the time if I
if I give you ten thousand images of
clock faces a data scientist would
figure out pretty quickly how to learn
the cosine of the hour hand and you
could just write a line of code you know
you could tell the time whereas if you
put it into an auto ml algorithm it
would do all sorts of weird and
wonderful things and it would encode
Stafford it probably wouldn't work
anyway because most of them a structured
data not for vision data but it's just a
classic example of if I just if I used
my brain and did something a little bit
intelligent rather than just throwing it
into this algorithm that just permutes
all of this random stuff and then it
produces something that I don't
necessarily understand how it works
is is that is that a good thing I think
to your imagination on it like something
like auto ml0
it's like as long as your task has a lot
of like robustness and like edge cases
built into the evaluation of it like
this kind of texture search is really
exciting to me I don't understand the
skeptic computing though but like don't
you think like a program synthesis
searching for just the program is pretty
exciting and can come up with more than
we could I think that's different I
think
0:02 ml0 designs because in the deep
learning world it is a black box and the
input and the output is fixed whereas I
think these auto ml algorithms that are
on let's say as you're an AWS they they
also encode all of the information and
they try lots of different algorithms
and it it seems to be a little bit more
diffuse I suppose Auto ml0 is just
learning a whole bunch of different
combinations of functions between an
input and an output yeah I think it's
like there's levels to the search space
it's like with a small search space
we'll do like like learning raters
number of layers we'll do like grid
search then random search then we're
doing like Bayesian optimization with a
Gaussian process then we start to get
into a more mid to large scale Auto mill
where we might use like a reinforced
learning controller and evolution search
or recently we're seeing like
differentiable search like darts if
someone's interested in looking into it
but like this evolution search with Auto
ml it's like this large-scale massive
server space I think that is just can be
it's like Jeff Clun in his paper
AIGA as he talks about we can either
find all of these building blocks of AI
and then take on the task of how do we
put all the building blocks we found
together or we could do something like
Auto ml0 that could discover the
combination and all the building blocks
at once so maybe maybe Zac you in in the
kinds of Auto ml you know what are the
kind of smartest things in there what
what are the kind of things that maybe
if you just if you're just a programmer
going about this you wouldn't put in
there yeah I think the the real benefit
of Auto ml in this context is it's a
Productivity tool and it it's more about
reproducibility
and robustness and codifying best
practices and the prior knowledge of our
experts of they have been working in
this space and it's like there's a
tremendous value in being able to click
a button and it in the same way every
time pull the data in process the data
and like do the transformations do the
same search and then having this you
know unit test integration test stitched
together in these pipelines modularity
and taking like the best practices of
software engineering and applying that
to this thing it's like to me we all if
you build a lot of machine learning
models you have like your own tool set
that you've developed you know I have
this code over here and I kind of
structure it this way and maybe I take a
jupiter notebook and first i do this and
that but i don't know about you guys but
I've always had this fantasy of sort of
getting more principled about that of
having a you know a repoed that is
really deliberate about designing the
library and the API is so that just
makes it really easy to iterate quickly
and I only have to write certain code
once and I can rely on it and I think
auto ml takes advantage of that because
in my experience there's so many bugs
that get introduced that are hard to
find when you're building models
particularly if people are in like two
paternoville environments and then it's
just this question of how do you apply
software engineering principles and
testing and integration testing but in
the context of machine learning that's
something to do before you run cell 3
you must run cell 5 well one thing that
worries me is that if you remove too
much of the friction out of the machine
learning process the the lack of due
diligence will create a deficit
somewhere else so if you have a
governance process in your machine
learning lifecycle you might say well
how explainable does it need to be
what's the severity of this model what
goes wrong if this thing makes the wrong
decision and so on and it
there should be a kind of process there
where you say okay well in that case I
need to have this type of model after I
built the model I need to have this
level of explained ability I might use
you know Lyman shap and some of these
interactive methods of explaining
ability the m/l engineer's might go
ahead and create some semantic testing
to test the robustness and the fairness
and the bias and all of that and these
are all very deliberate things that need
to be done and it just seems to me that
in the in the grand scheme of things
Otto mo doesn't really save you any time
it might even cost you time because
later on the ml engineer's gonna be
tearing their hair out saying I don't
even understand how this thing works and
how do i semantically test this what's a
good test for this because it's just a
black box as far as they're concerned
yeah I don't think all ml Otto ml
solutions have to create these
complicated black box ensembles and
stuff like that but you could do that
and I think a lot of the existing open
source solutions that is their technique
right it's that they're trying all these
different things and all's they care
about is improving the performance on
the holdout set and all that and then of
course there's all these questions of
well how do you actually create the
training and hold out sets because your
decisions at that point can have such
enormous consequences on the results I
think people that compete on Kaggle have
really taken that to heart because it
entirely comes down to how you are doing
your holdout evaluation and getting on a
test set that's such a critically
important thing and it's something that
I think there's a lot of magic in the
Otto amel piece there that if you're
really principled about how you do that
and you try different things you can
make a lot of progress that it's just
really hard to duplicate that as an
individual all the time unless you have
access to some code base that someone
else or you have developed and really
made sure it's bulletproof so that's one
piece the second piece is that what
you've described of generating the model
and the reports first of all I think a
lot of that can be automated the
reporting side which is valuable in
itself but once you do that and you sign
off and say okay now we want to put this
thing in production well how do you put
this thing in production and not screw
up so like I've applied these
transformations during training and I
need to make sure it's these exact same
transformation
that are applied at inference time and a
lot can go wrong in that process of
translating from the things somebody
built over here and the thing that's
running in production particularly of
software engineers that are used to a
different stack like Java or something
or you know someone tosses it over the
fence like a our regulatory office and
whatever we've signed off on this so
please go implement it that can be
dangerous right
so another thing in Auto ml pipeline can
do is take that ops pain away and create
it in such a manner that you have a lot
of confidence because it's using for
instance the same code base under the
hood to do this versus that or it's
serialized it in some clever way and it
it was baked in from the beginning right
yeah you can produce an auto airmail
prediction model and then in inference
when you productionize your model on a
flask web server or something on usually
it's on Cuban ETS or it might be on Sage
maker you're saying because the same
code is running you know the model will
be able to understand the data but I'm
just a certain thing but that then means
that you couldn't operationalize it
let's say on spark on your data Lake
yeah I think it depends how you
structure it so that's just a challenge
in general with all these different
frameworks like spark has its own kind
of thing carved out and it's really hard
to get something from for instance
scikit-learn to spark there's like this
in leap library that has had some
development that allows you to kind of
do that or things like XG boost have
ways that you can create a java class
and then maybe you can call that using
something like man I forget the name of
an Alvin there's all sorts of these
intermediary representations like onyx
that are trying to be agnostic about the
framework and then there's some
serialization scheme that takes it from
one into this and then there's a scoring
engine but I think we're at this place
now where so many people use so many
different things and that that's great
and it's interesting and it serves like
the research community we've been
getting it in production is another
thing because a lot of those engineering
stacks are in Java for instance so how
do you get it from here to there and
people create things but to me that's
still a big kind of Wild West situation
where there's been things like PMML the
fa onyx all these solutions that are
tend to do that but there hasn't been
like this clear winner of this is what
the industry is going to do so right now
it's still just a big challenge and
getting something that automates that is
a huge success for a business at this
point that's fair I think the
automaticity is the big thing here that
there's that reproducibility that
getting away from human error and my
intuitive aversion is just because of
the lack of visibility just being able
to understand what it does but in
principle there's no reason why you
couldn't generate some kind of a
computation graph we're a workflow which
I could visualize so I could still
understand exactly what you were doing
but you're saving me a lot of time in
the process yeah I also think there's a
gap between what I have in mind but I'm
thinking about Otto and Mel which really
is about this as you're describing this
automation piece plus kind of codifying
best practices which also includes some
high parameter search and stuff like
that but that's very different than what
a lot of people think about with Otto
and Mel and a lot of the open source
solutions of this thing that runs maybe
an evolutionary algorithm under the hood
and just tries all this different stuff
and ensembles and you end up with this
huge model that does God knows what and
it's really hard to audit right that is
called Otto amel and maybe is what most
people think of when they use the term
and I don't have much confidence in that
myself is something that's going to
greatly move the needle unless it moves
to a different area but not probably to
democratize in the short term but you
know I haven't thought that much about
that I've been more focused on the
production izing for businesses and
making it robust and bulletproof okay I
think that's a really good distinction I
think my conception of Auto ml was let's
try loads of random things a little bit
like architecture sir so let's try and
encoding this thing as a categorical
let's try and coding it as a number
let's try doing this that's try doing
this let's try this algorithm let's try
this type of parameter I think I know
the azure service is actually a little
bit data-driven so they know if I've
seen this type of rectangular data with
this number of columns before this
particular algorithm with this set of
hyper parameters work well before so
let's try that and you know but it just
seems arbitrary yeah I think that's a
fair criticism and I just don't have
much experience with them in practice
but sort of as an outsider looking at
that I agree I have some concerns there
but as Connor was alluding to I I don't
think it's ruled out as an opportunity
to do really cool things in the future I
don't think it's it's probably there yet
and you know really they just have
wrappers around some some search stuff
and have tried to like piece together
the inputs and outputs and maybe
automate some stacking ensemble stuff
but you know that that's really just
some scripts that are running on your
data set right when you call dot fit it
does a few more things so to me that is
interesting but it's not going to solve
any of the fundamental problems I face
because in my world getting the next 1%
of accuracy or whatever like I'm not
trying to get state-of-the-art results
on some data set so that I can publish
in a paper ignoring the cost of
implementation what I really want is
something that I can rely on and can do
a good job and then in a month when I
have more data and the fraudsters have
changed their patterns I can click the
button and get something just as
reliable that has the most recent
information and it's auto-generated a
lot of the reporting so the auditing
process is easy and all that stuff like
that's what I need not the next 2%
because it did some cool stacking thing
I can't argue with that and you can't
trust these numbers anyway when Yannick
reviewed the you know the bring your own
latent paper they reproduced the
algorithm from sim CLR and the numbers
were completely different and that just
that the sensitivity of these algorithms
to different hyper parameters I mean
that'd be why oh well people didn't even
release the code for their paper they
just released pseudo code which doesn't
exactly inspire confidence that's just
the mind
it's just deep mud okay well it's being
emotional there's a lot of thank you
yeah thank you so much for joining is
exactly I hope you join us again yeah
this was fun
any time and hopefully you guys can I
don't know we can think of something
else to do
like interview or livestream on the
other channel as well to get you guys in
front of a different audience but or
maybe it's the exact same audience I
don't know but anyway yeah I think
there's there's some things we can do to
keep collaborating for sure amazing well
thank you so much for joining us